so ist der böse becher wir haben
normalerweise ein großes glas wir finden
es nicht aber die fragen hummer gefunden
deswegen hier wieder etwas wie es jetzt
genau die rote hose und böse die grünen
da musst du kannst das ist es einfach so
dass ich die roten nimmt er hat einfach
den reiz sich eine böse frage durch
zuletzt mächtig genau und er sollte uns
antworten
aber es gab auch schon fälle habe ich
gehört wo sie nicht beantwortet worden
war
beantwortet doch nix kaputt so weg
gelegt aber es gab auch schon kleinere
ausbrüche und so weiter du kommst doch
aus einer gebildeten familie könntest du
dich nicht etwas gewählter in deinen
songs ausdrücken
also mich würde es wirklich richtig
krass interessieren wer diese frage
gestellt hat falls das einer meiner fans
ist dann freue ich mich über diese frage
ja wie ich gerade im interview erklärt
hat die letzten jahre haben mich ein
bisschen auf den anderen weg geführt und
halt mein sprachgebrauch hat auch ein
bisschen darunter gelitten
und wie gesagt probiere ich mich jetzt
probiere ich mein wortschatz sind wieder
ein bisschen durch literatur und
gewisses training aufzufrischen und
extra für dich werde ich probiere mich
jetzt in zukunft gewählt auszudrücken
ich weiß nicht ich habe keine ahnung was
sagen deine eltern dazu hat die nicht am
anfang den markt eingetreten diese
sprache ja gewisse songs zeige ich meine
eltern manchmal gibt sogar die chance wo
ich wirklich gefühl wenn sich die meine
eltern zeigen würde die winde tränen
kommen aber ich mache das nur an und
gehören aus dem raum braucht weil ich
kann nicht dabei sein so ein bisschen
zusammen michael jackson sagt man dass
er nach der hat immer hinter dem sofa
kopf wenn er seine neuen songs verwiesen
hat okay weil er sich geschämt hat das
ist ein peinlicher hockey tun dann erst
gute meiner lieben schlechte frauen wie
bist du darauf gekommen einen so
einfühlsam song zu machen
wie gesagt ist eine wahre geschichte aus
meinem leben ich wollte an dem punkt
dass wir diesem thema endgültig
abschließen wollte und weil ich halt
doch wusste dass ich für mich jetzt
gerade als nähme das letzte mal darüber
zu schreiben habe ich auch noch mal aus
mir raus brodeln lassen
ich hatte mich hat die muse geküsst und
ich hab ich habe ich habe mein gefühl
freien lauf gelassen hat mich nochmal in
die zeit zurück versetzt das ja auch
lange her und dann ging es auf jeden
fall ist eine wahre geschichte und jeden
dienst gut tue diesen songs hören freut
mich am morgen wollen oder grün-rot noch
auf jeden fall ein bisschen mehr spaß
ja
mache ich alles alle mal hast du dich
mit haftbefehl dann wieder nicht also
was denn
also diese frage kommt wohl daher
zustande dass ich wohl letzten halt mal
in einem interview gesagt hat dass ich
nichts persönlich gegen habe und dass
ich niemanden sein brot wegnehmen will
oder sein geschäft kaputt machen will
wie gesagt für mich ist das musikalische
sache beef mit haftbefehl habe ich
sowieso nicht in dem sinne weil da bis
jetzt noch kein austausch gewesen ist in
der öffentlichkeit
ich habe ihn ja und ich stehe zu meinem
statement aber das statement was ich
abgegeben hat hat sich auch noch bezogen
auf die dinge die er gemacht hat zudem
ließ phase seines zweiten albums davon
macht er jetzt nicht mehr unbedingt viel
vielleicht habe ich noch wach gehört und
was weiß ich
und wie gesagt wie habe ich mit
niemandem ein statement gesagt und ich
werde immer wieder mit statement sein
ja aber wenn wir uns sehen morgen werden
wir uns auf jeden fall nicht in die arme
fallen falls sich das interessiert ich
mache alle fragen ich bin ich sie wieder
bewusst in dir selbst wie kriegst du das
in den aufregenden rap geschäften wie
kommst du darauf dass ich in mir selber
ruhe
weißt du dass keine informationen dazu
ausgeglichen ist also meinte es jetzt
also das in der öffentlichkeit komme ich
nur übertroffen
ja ich probiere natürlich fassen da
draußen
nein ich bin ging's natürlich ich werde
jetzt auch wenn ich mal es gibt auch mal
interview zwischen teil kopf gekriegt
bin selber kreiert was zusammen probleme
jetzt 15 minuten jetzt nicht nach außen
zu zeigen dass oder total durch bis zum
kopf es gibt tage wo ich ein bisschen
die fassung verlieren die kontrolle
verlieren und vieles einen akt auf gut
englisch und aber so ich probiert zu
bleiben und probiert das ganze auch
wieder ein bisschen lockerer zu sehen
gerade jetzt auch wenn es nicht so
rüberkam jetzt in der
dies habe zu meinem album vieles wirkt
ich mich zwischen echt ein bisschen
durchgenommen
das wie gesagt ihr müsst mir da auch
diese musik war leidenschaft gewesen und
jetzt geht es einfach darum alles muss
funktionieren und das muss so unter
business und hier und ich probiere
wieder einmal kobe wieder das ganze ding
ein bisschen meine musik ist immer echt
unwirtschaftlich gewesen aber halten die
leidenschaften und mal wieder bisher
mehr im vordergrund zu stellen und 50 50
wenn ich hinkriegen dann freut es mich
ich probiere einfach ich selber zu
bleiben mich nicht von allen mitzureißen
was in der außenwelt passiert nehmen und
überlegen ist das keine frage die auf
diese frage wagt sich schon den ganzen
abend man leute games ist das ganze
gewissen nur show um mehr aufmerksamkeit
innerhalb der rapper szene zu bekommen
so eine liebe freunde max sache ist die
man muss es ja aber so sehen es gibt
rapper was ich jetzt auch gar nicht
kritisieren will die haben ihre gesamte
karriere von vornherein darauf ausgelegt
andere wetter zu wissen ich habe ein
erstes album rausgebracht um jemanden zu
wissen ich habe ein zweites album
rausgebracht oder jemanden zu wissen nun
konnte auch meinen ersten chart erfolg
verbuchen und jetzt bei meinem dritten
album habe ich mein maul aufgerissen und
mein statement abgegeben zu gewissen
dingen die passiert sind die letzten
jahre habe das auch gemacht weil ich das
halt immer in mir gesammelt habe aber
die ersten zwei alben gerade bewusst
auch dafür genutzt habe nicht zu wissen
und dinge aus meinem leben zu
verarbeiten und da war ich halt wirklich
den punkt dass so viele leute nach außen
sachen der typ ist depressiv alter der
musiker tree und ich war auch selber
einen punkt ich gesagt okay jetzt
mal wieder ein bisschen action rap dies
dass und da hat es für mich einfach
gepasst halt auch mal wieder zu sagen
was ich denke und meinen gefühlen und
meinem statement freien lauf zu lassen
das ist für mich kein gesetz um
aufmerksamkeit zu kriegen aber da will
ich auch mal ganz ehrlich sagen wenn ein
rapper der keine daseinsberechtigung
oder keine relevanz hat einen disstrack
in jemand macht wird er damit auch keine
aufmerksamkeit kriegen das heißt wenn
ich nicht schon existent gewesen wäre
und nicht gut wäre und kein killer
rapper wäre hätte ich hier keine
aufmerksamkeit damit bekommen und
deswegen jährige richtig dass jetzt die
kameraführung ist vollkommen
unbeeindruckt viele mit deiner
intelligenz wie hast du es geschafft
dann nicht überheblich zu werden
mein management sagt mir immer du kommst
in interviews voll überheblich darüber
ehrlich ärgert mich wohl damit ich
verstehe dass wir jedes mal total
bodenständig und dort sein heiße sind
wieder das bedeutet überheblich
überhaupt für mich gibt es keinen grund
irgendwie überheblich zu werden für mich
ist ich weiß nicht genau so wie ist für
viele leute zur männlichkeit gehört
stark zu sein sich nicht gefallen zu
lassen und das gehört auch zu meiner
männlichkeit finde finde ich es gehört
auch zur männlichkeit sich ausdrucken zu
können
eine gewisse intelligenz zu haben
gebildet zu sein nicht einfach wie
vollidiot zu leben und das für mich
etwas ganz normales
etwas was jeder mensch haben sollte und
sehe ich keinen grund irgendwie deswegen
überheblich zu sein aber wenn ich viele
damit beeindrucken kann weil so viele
halt blöd sind dann ist es vorteilhaft
für mich und finde ich cool
vielen dank super hat mich gefreut mich
ab jak